la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire de la proposition de loi
visant à renforcer la protection des
familles d'enfants atteint d'une maladie
ou d'un handicap ou victime d'un
accident d'une particular d'une
particulière pardon gravité la parole
est à Monsieur Paul Christophe
rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur ministre à
Madame la vice-présente mes chers
collègues après une adoption à
l'unanimité le 2 mars et le 4 juillet
dernier respectivement à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat la proposition de
loi visant à renforcé la protection des
familles d'enfants atteints d'une
maladie ou d'un handicap ou victime d'un
accident d'une partie oculaire gravité
que j'ai l'honneur de vous proposer
termine son cheminement parlementaire
avec succès par une commission mixte
paritaire conclusive je ne peux vous
cacher mon plaisir de voir aboutir cette
proposition loi dans seulement 5 mois le
Parlement s'est montré à la hauteur des
attentes des parents et des associations
qui portent leur voix cette proposition
de loi s'inscrit ainsi dans la
continuité du travail parlementaire mené
et suivi depuis de nombreuses années sur
ce sujet je pense notamment aux lois de
Nathalie Limas en 2019 de Christophe
déjà en 2021 Bricout Descamps mais
également au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2022 qui revalorisa le montant de la
location journalière de présence
parentale à hauteur du SMIC je tiens à
dire que la liste des textes cités
précédemment et la preuve de
l'engagement constant et durable des
parlementaires comme du gouvernement sur
ces enjeux par l'adoption définitive de
cette proposition de loi nous
poursuivons notre objectif de faciliter
la vie des parents concernés afin de ne
pas ajouter une peine supplémentaire à
ceux qui voient leur quotidien
bouleversé je dirais même percuter par
l'annonce d'une maladie ou d'un handicap
chez l'enfant nous ne cherchons ni
audience 10 spectacle peu importe que
nos lois ne fassent pas grand bruit tant
que nous obtenons de grands effets
par des mesures de protection et de
simplification cette dispositions Vista
soulager les familles d'une partie des
difficultés administratives financières
ou professionnelles qui pèsent sur elle
des dispositions qui ont su nous unir
car nous connaissons tous un proche qui
est tout à la fois par an soignant
accompagnateurs
lorsque la situation l’exige ce proche
peut alors être contraint de réduire son
temps de travail ou d'interrompre son
activité professionnelle pour s'occuper
de son enfant qui peut s'en offusquer
les rendez-vous qui s'enchaînent à
l'hôpital à l'école ou avec
l'administration
use et inquiète ce proche qui tentent de
préserver son enfant de ses propres
angoisses il nous revient alors sur la
base de la solidarité nationale de
tendre la main à ce proche et de lui
apporter tout le répit et la protection
dont il a besoin la présente proposition
de loi en renforcer la protection de
tous ses parents courageux qui se
battent pour leur enfant par l'article
premier nous les protégeons du risque de
licenciement quand ils sont contraints
de réduire leur activité professionnelle
sur le modèle du positif déjà existant
pour le congé maternité de paternité ou
de deuil compte tenu notre volonté
commune d'améliorer le texte l'ensemble
des députés et des sénateurs ont trouvé
un accord sur la rédaction de l'article
premier bis par celui-ci nous portons à
14 jours la durée minimale du congé pour
le décès d'un enfant de moins de 25 ans
et à 12 jours quel que soit son âge rien
ne permettra au législateur que nous
sommes devenir compenser la perte d'un
enfant mais l'adoption de ces
disposition constitue une avancée pour
l'accompagnement des familles
endeuillées par l'article 2 nous
facilitons le recours au télétravail
pour les salariés aidants d'un enfant
d'un parent ou d'un proche par l'article
3 nous simplifions le renouvellement de
la JPP et du CPP en supprimant la
condition d'un accord préalable
explicite du service de contrôle médical
et permettant un versement d'une avance
par les services de la CAF
pas l'article 4 nous supprimons les
mesures décrètement de la JPP et de la
JPA par l'article 4 bis nous protégeons
les familles contre le risque d'une
rupture de bail par le propriétaire
lorsque celui-ci souhaite reprendre ou
vendre le logement enfin par l'article 5
nous lançons une expérimentation auprès
des caisses d'allocations familiales
visant à améliorer la situation des
bénéficiaires de la JPP rencontrant des
difficultés financières ou un besoin
d'accompagnement complémentaire vous
l'aurez compris cette proposition en
temps mettre fin à certaines
discriminations subies par les parents
d'enfants atteints d'une maladie ou d'un
handicap même si nous ne prêtons pas
répondre à toutes les difficultés
qu'elles rencontrent nous poursuivons
notre travail par l'adoption d'avancer
concrète portée par les associations
je souhaite remercier en premier lieu
tous les bénévoles toutes les
associations qui partout tout le temps
œuvrent dans l'ombre et avec dévouement
pour l'accompagnement des familles
notamment l'association EVA pour la vie
la Fédération grandir sans cancer et son
infertigable président Stéphane Védrenne
je remercie le président Laurent Marc
Angeli et les membres de la de notre
groupe horizon et à parenté qui m'ont
fait confiance et permis d'inscrire ce
texte je remercie le gouvernement et
tout particulièrement Monsieur le
Ministre Jean-Christophe Kong qui s'est
montré à l'écoute de nos préoccupations
et avec qui nous avons pu construire un
texte équilibré je remercie bien
évidemment les deux présidents de
commission mesdames katabi et de roche
ainsi que les sénatrices Brigitte
micolot et Marie-Pierre Richer toutes
celles et ceux qui nous ont soutenu dans
ce travail y compris nos administrateurs
chers Alix et chers Thomas pour conclure
je tiens à saluer l'esprit constructif
dans lequel s'est déroulée l'examen de
cette proposition de loi ne doutant pas
chers collègues d'un vote unanime de
tous les groupes politiques preuves de
notre attachement commun à la cause des
aidants je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe combe
ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées
merci madame la présidente Madame la
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
aujourd'hui avec une très grande
reconnaissance pour le travail mené par
Paul Christophe et pour l'accord trouvé
entre l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
que je me présente devant vous à l'heure
dacter l'adoption définitive de cette
proposition de loi c'est aussi avec une
pensée particulière pour les familles
concernées par les situations dont le
texte traite pour les parents d'enfants
malades pour les foyers et les fratries
affectées par ces épreuves de la vie
nous y sommes toutes et tous sensibles
et l'accueil réservé à l'initiative du
groupe horizon son enrichissement au fil
de la navette parlementaire en est la
meilleure preuve nous y sommes sensibles
parce que pour certains nous avons vécu
ces situations parce que pour d'autres
nous avons été interpellés par des
familles ou par des associations
mobilisées engagées et qui accompagne
les parents au quotidien je remercie à
ce titre et à nouveau l'action du réseau
grandir sans cancer
c'est avant tout pour ces familles que
le gouvernement et la représentation
nationale ont avancé conjointement sur
ce texte pour mieux prendre en compte
les difficultés qu'elles rencontrent au
quotidien et y apporter des réponses
renforcées pour davantage symboliser la
solidarité de la nation je n'ai
énumérerai pas toutes les mesures
puissantes que contient ce texte dont
l'utilité se vérifiera très rapidement
pour des milliers de familles mais
simplement vous dire qu'elle viendront
compléter tout ce qui existait déjà vous
l'avez dit cher Paul grâce à l'adoption
en 2019 de la loi visant à renforcer la
prise en charge des cancers pédiatriques
par la recherche le soutien aux aidants
familiaux la formation des
professionnels et le droit à l'oubli
grâce à l'adoption en 2021 de la loi
Visante à l'accompagnement des enfants
atteints de pathologies chroniques ou de
cancer grâce à l'adoption toujours en
2021 de la loi visant à améliorer les
conditions de présence parentale auprès
d'un enfant dont la nécessite un
accompagnement soutenu dans la
continuité de ces textes le texte de
Paul Christophe viendra par exemple
renforcer et simplifier la mobilisation
du dispositif de congé et d'allocations
journalières de présence parentale
c'était une demande de longue date des
personnes concernées légitimes et sur
laquelle toutes les sensibilités
présentes dans cette assemblée se sont
retrouvés il sera demain plus simple de
solliciter pour la première fois
l'ouverture de ses droits avec une
liquidation de la prestation pour
laquelle il n'y aura plus besoin
d'attendre la vie du service de contrôle
médical de la caisse d'assurance maladie
il sera aussi plus facile de solliciter
un renouvellement exceptionnel de ces
droits dans les cas où cela est
nécessaire pour les parents d'un enfant
dont la situation ne s'est pas
suffisamment améliorée
ces mesures s'inscrivent pleinement dans
la logique du gouvernement en faveur de
l'accès rapide et effectif au droit ce
sont des questions au cœur du dialogue
que je mène avec l'ensemble des acteurs
en particulier avec la Caisse nationale
des allocations familiales de plus en
plus ouvertes qui modernis ces pratiques
les adaptes aux attentes et aux besoins
de nos concitoyens j'insisterai aussi
simplement sur les dispositions de ce
texte visant à allonger la durée des
congés pour deuils d'enfant et pour
annonce de la survenue d'un handicap ou
d'une affection de longue durée de
l'enfant c'est allongement à
l'initiative de l'Assemblée nationale
compléter au Sénat par le gouvernement
notamment pour l'adapter aux agents de
la fonction publique offrira des
respirations indispensables aux parents
concernés par ces situations pour
certaines difficiles et pour d'autres
dramatiques nous le savons bien faire
son deuil dans certains cas prendre la
mesure de la situation nouvelle et des
bouleversements induits dans d'autres
nécessitent du temps
dans ces considérations la place des
entreprises et bien sûr centrale et ce
texte la consacre il nous faut de plus
en plus parler au delà de leur
responsabilités environnementale et
sociales d'une nouvelle responsabilité à
affirmer à assumer une responsabilité
familiale elle a très avant tout à une
organisation qui tienne compte de la
dimension parentale du salarié et donc
de l'intérêt des enfants beaucoup
d'entreprises l'ont déjà compris et je
souhaite que cette tendance s'accélère
ces enjeux sont sans doute plus
prégnants que jamais nous devons
soutenir davantage les parents c'est
fameuses aventuriers du monde moderne
dont parlait Peggy à chaque étape
qu'elle soit heureuse ou difficile alors
je ne serai pas plus long mesdames et
messieurs les députés car vous savez
comme moi ce que ce texte contient et
qu'il contient de nombreuses avancées
pour les familles il nous faudra bien
sûr aller plus loin je sais que c'est
déjà le souhait de beaucoup d'entre vous
et je suis convaincu que cela passe
notamment par des initiatives locales
des retours d'expérience des
expérimentations et à ce titre le
gouvernement soutenait pleinement
l'article 5 de ce texte puisque
l'expérimentation qu'il prévoit
permettra notamment au CAF de rester
souple et de proposer aux bénéficiaires
qu'elles accompagnent des aménagements
qui si nous ne les connaissons pas
aujourd'hui auront peut-être demain
vocation à être généralisée la question
se posera en tout cas toujours en
relation avec les parents dont nous
devons entendre les besoins et les
attentes et avec les professionnels qui
les accompla panne et savent déjà nous
dire doivent d'ailleurs continuer à nous
dire ce qui fonctionne et ce qui doit
être amélioré je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre nous en
venons à la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur François Gernigon
pour le groupe horizon et apparenté
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous nous
apprêtons à voter s'adresse à une
situation complexe et difficile à gérer
pour les familles qui voient leur enfant
atteint d'une maladie d'un handicap ou
qui est victime d'un accident d'une
particulière gravité
chaque année près de 2500 enfants ou
adolescents sont diagnostiqués d'un
cancer et ces chiffres sont en
augmentation en Europe depuis de
nombreuses années
des moyens importants pour faire
diminuer ce drame qui touche de
nombreuses familles sont mises en place
de nombreux textes ont été adoptés ces
dernières années pour renforcer la
protection des projets dents et des
familles notamment plusieurs de notre
collègue Paul Christophe et témoignent
de l'engagement que nous portons à
soutenir les familles dans les moments
difficiles et améliorer leur quotidien
cependant des obstacles et notamment des
freins administratifs compliquent encore
inutilement la vie de ces familles en
détresse
les parents d'enfants malades sont
confrontés à une épreuve extrêmement
difficile qui bouleverse non seulement
leur vie mais également celle de toute
la famille
très tôt les enfants prennent conscience
de la gravité de leur situation
il remarque que toute la tension de la
famille est tournée vers eux le regard
d'autres enfants ils comprennent et
intègrent dans leur quotidien très
rapidement les termes techniques liés à
leur maladie telles que aplasie ou
transfusion
de même ils apprennent à parler de leur
caté ou de leur chambre d'hôpital
pour aider l'enfant malade à faire face
à la maladie les parents doivent être
particulièrement présents et soutenant
mais cela peut s'avérer être une tâche
difficile et épuisante à laquelle aucun
parent ne peut se préparer
il est alors important de soutenir les
parents notamment en leur offrant une
assistance pratique pour alléger le
fardeau qu'il porte
ce texte apporte plusieurs modifications
législatives importantes il cherche
intégrer dans le code du travail une
protection contre le licenciement pour
tout parents salariés contraint de
réduire ou cesser son activité
il propose d'allonger le congé annonçant
un handicap ou une maladie grave à 5
jours et celui pour le décès d'un enfant
à 14 jours pour les moins de 25 ans et
12 jours pour les plus âgés
il envisage le télétravail comme un
aménagement de poste nécessaire pour les
salariés confrontés à une maladie grave
ou un handicap d'un enfant à charge
ainsi que pour tous les aidants
familiaux
de plus il prévoit de simplifier le
renouvellement de la demande d'agitp
il propose également une protection pour
les familles contre les ruptures de bail
pour le propriétaire le propriétaire
enfin il suggère une évaluation du
dispositif de complément pour frais de
la JPP versé mensuellement à certaines
familles dans Format malade dans le
cadre d'une expérimentation
nous saluons également le bon esprit
collectif qui a permis l'enrichissement
de cette proposition de loi avec de
nouvelles propositions en tenant compte
des demandes des familles et des
parlementaires et qui a conduit à son
adoption unanime tant à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'au Sénat
le groupe horizon s'engage auprès des
familles touchées par la maladie et le
handicap et propose des réponses
concrètes et opérationnelles aux
familles dont l'enfant est victime d'une
maladie grave d'un handicap ou qui est
victime d'un accident d'une particulière
gravité
il est important également de souligner
le rôle essentiel joué par les
associations dans le soutien des
familles touchées par la maladie grave
ou l'accident de la vie de leur enfant
ces associations apportent une aide
précieuse non seulement en termes de
soutien moral et psychologique si
important mais aussi en termes
d'assistance pratique pour aider les
familles à surmonter les nombreux
obstacles qu'elle rencontre dans leur
vie quotidienne
leur soutien est souvent inestimable
nous voterons donc évidemment cette
proposition de loi portée par notre
collègue Paul Christophe que nous
remercions pour son travail et son
engagement sur ce sujet depuis de
longues années je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame marie-charlotte-garin pour le
groupe les écologistes
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous devons nous
prononcer aujourd'hui sur un
chamboulement qui peut toucher la vie de
certains de nos compatriotes celle de
voir son enfant victime d'une maladie
grave ce bouleversement dans la vie de
la famille impose aux parents de changer
parfois radicalement leur mode de vie
pour être présent pour accompagner au
mieux leurs enfants
cette proposition de loi entend apporter
une première réponse à la détresse
financière et administrative que vivent
les parents d'enfants atteint d'une
maladie grave ou d'un handicap
nos collègues sénateurs et sénatrices se
sont alignés avec l'intention de
l'assemblée de garantir un régime de
télétravail plus protecteur que la
rédaction initiale pour les salariés
dont l'enfant est atteint d'une maladie
ou d'un handicap en s'alignant avec le
régime appliqué aux femmes enceintes et
travaillant handicapées le Sénat a
également soutenu les mesures visant à
prévenir un refus par le bailleur de
renouvellement de bail à un locataire
bénéficiaire de l'allocation journalière
de présence parentale cette mesure est
particulièrement nécessaire car il est
aujourd'hui impensable que les parents
d'enfants malades déjà précarisés se
retrouvent également en difficulté pour
se loger les débats ont commission mixte
paritaire sur les autres articles ont
mené un consensus que le groupe
écologiste salue le texte issu de la
commission mix paritaire a retenu
plusieurs enrichissements apportés par
le Sénat ils ont été les bienvenus le
Sénat a ainsi permis une meilleure
protection des salariés sollicitant un
congé de présence parentale contre les
licenciements abusifs en précisant que
cela doit également concerner les congés
de présence parentale fractionnés ou à
temps partiel nous saluons aussi
l'extension du congé pour le décès d'un
enfant adopté par le Sénat qui a porté à
14 jours la durée minimale du congé pour
le décès d'un enfant de moins de 25 ans
et à 12 jours quel que soit son âge et
là et a étendu la mesure à la fonction
publique je ne peux à titre personnel
imaginer la douleur terrible liée à la
perte d'un enfant mais nous avons un
devoir absolu d'empathie à l'égard des
salariés victimes de cet événement
tragique
si nous saluons l'extension de ce congé
à 14 jours ainsi que les autres
enrichissements apportés par le Sénat et
adoptés par la commission mixte
paritaire le groupe écologiste exprime
toutefois des regrets sur des
améliorations supplémentaires que nous
avions portées en séance et en
commission et qui n'ont pas été retenus
nous sommes en effet conscient que la
survenue d'une maladie grave ou d'un
handicap engendre bien souvent des
difficultés financières qui offrait
médicaux parfois très élevé et non pris
en charge par la Sécurité Sociale de
fait nous rappelons à ce sujet que près
d'un ménage sur quatre touchant la
location la location d'éducation de
l'enfant handicapé puis sous le seuil de
pauvreté et cette précarité elle touche
d'ailleurs particulièrement les femmes
et les mères célibataires dans un
contexte où le taux de divorce et de 85%
dans cette situation
beaucoup de mères sont alors forcés de
réduire voire de quitter leur travail
pour s'occuper de leur enfant ce qui
diminue considérablement leurs
ressources malgré les aides actuelles et
qu'il est pénalise notamment pour la
retraite nous n'oublions pas que ce sont
d'ailleurs les femmes qui seront
davantage pénalisées par la dernière
réforme que nous venons de subir de fait
le groupe écologiste rappelle que
protéger les parents d'enfants atteints
de maladies graves ou d'un handicap
c'est d'abord s'assurer que cet
événement n'aura pas de conséquences
financières fatales sur le montant de
leur retraite au-delà de ce préjudice
économique sur le long terme nous
aurions pu aller plus loin dans le cadre
de cette proposition de loi nous aurions
aimé que la majorité prenne également en
compte qu'avoir un enfant atteint d'une
maladie grave ou d'un handicap ne peut
non seulement pas décemment être un
motif de licenciement mais cela ne peut
mener à d'autres discriminations dans
l'emploi
de plus compte tenu de la responsabilité
de l'État de libérer les familles
concernées de la charge mentale de
survie financièrement d'autres
propositions que nous avions portées
aurait pu être envisagées telles que
l'exemption d'un parent d'un enfant
malade ou en situation de handicap
débiteur de ses obligations de
remboursement de crédit nous avions
également proposé d'expérimenter
l'extension du dispositif communauté 360
aux parents concernés comme c'est le cas
actuellement pour les personnes en
situation de handicap ce dispositif
permet un accompagnement global de la
personne dans la gestion du quotidien et
des procédures administratives et cela
nous semble fondamental
cette mesure était d'ailleurs dans le
rapport de la mission gouvernementale
sur l'accompagnement des parents
d'enfants malades présentés par Monsieur
Paul Christophe nous regrettons donc que
le Parlement ne s'y soit pas intéressé
enfin nous appelons à engager plus
largement un travail sur le statut
d'aidant dont le rôle est encore bien
trop souvent synonyme de précarité et de
manque de reconnaissance le groupe
écologiste soutiendra le texte issu de
la commission mixte paritaire et
enrichie par les travaux des
parlementaires et continuera son combat
pour remettre le soin au cœur des
préoccupations de l'État je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Madame Soumia Bourou aha
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègue
apprendre que son enfant est touché par
une maladie grave un handicap ou un
accident d'une particulière gravité et
toujours pour les familles un drame
immense du jour au lendemain le
quotidien est complètement bouleversé
les priorités d'hier contrastent
terriblement avec celle de demain
c'est toute une organisation qui se
mette en place instantanément pour
répondre à ces nouvelles priorités en
plaçant au cœur de l'attention familiale
la santé de son enfant ses besoins et
ceux de la fratrie qui subissent tout
autant les conséquences de ce drame
l'inquiétude les rendez-vous médicaux et
les démarches administratives se
substituent aux tâches habituelles
agenda professionnel ainsi qu'aux autres
activités
pour un parent se transformer en proche
aidant n'est pas un choix c'est une
nécessité absolue qui s'impose et que
personne n'aurait pu prévenir pour
pouvoir accompagner son enfant dans de
bonnes conditions et continuer à
soutenir l'ensemble de la famille il
faut que chaque parent soit lui-même
bien accompagnée et qu'il puisse
bénéficier d'un cadre stable et
sécurisant dans une situation qui elle
est angoissante et imprévisible aussi
cette proposition de loi s'inscrit dans
la continuité des avancées obtenues lors
de la précédente législative en ouvrant
de nouveaux droits droits aux procédant
et plus particulièrement aux parents
d'enfants atteint d'une maladie grave
d'un handicap ou d'un grave accident
selon la Dares près d'un an sur deux
occupe un emploi parallèlement à son
engagement familial auprès d'un proche
dans la majorité des situations ce sont
les femmes qui assument ces deux rôles
simultan
continuer à occuper un emploi est
indispensable pour beaucoup de proches
aidants afin de conserver une
rémunération permettant d'assumer le
quotidien du foyer c'est pourquoi nous
nous ne pouvons que soutenir
l'interdiction de licencier un parent au
congé de présence parentale par ailleurs
l'aménagement du poste de travail grâce
au télétravail pour un parent est une
solution qui peut en partie en soulager
certains pour autant cette adaptation
doit être correctement encadrée afin que
la frontière entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie personnelle
soit bien respectée que cela n'est pas
un impact supplémentaire dans un cadre
familial déjà très complexe
en ce qui concerne l'article 3 le groupe
de la Gauche démocrate et républicaine
soutient la possibilité d'une avance de
l'allocation journalière de présence
parentale toutefois nous regrettons
qu'elle reste circonscrite à 310 jours
sur trois ans alors que malheureusement
les handicaps les maladies graves ou les
conséquences d'une grave accident ont
bien souvent des répercussions qui
répercussions sur la santé des jeunes
enfants au-delà de 3 ans enfin son
montant est limité à un forfait de 52
jours 52 euros par jour ce qui nous
apparaît insuffisant
ressenti lors de l'annonce de la maladie
d'un enfant sont des moments qui
plongent de nombreuses familles dans une
grande fragilité face à ces situations
exceptionnelles il est nécessaire
d'anticiper les difficultés
supplémentaires qui pourraient les faire
basculer dans une situation encore plus
douloureuse et pour certains dans une
gravité dans une grande précarité c'est
pourquoi protéger les familles qui
bénéficient de la location journalière
de présence parentale du non
renouvellement du bail de leur logement
en raison de la maladie de leurs enfants
leurs enfants est indispensable pour
protéger l'ensemble du foyer
lors de l'examen en première lecture de
ce texte à l'Assemblée ma collègue
Karine Lebon avait souligné la nécessité
de mieux cerner les difficultés
rencontrées par les parents de mineurs
ultramarins dont l'accès aux soins
nécessite une évacuation sanitaire vers
l'Hexagone cette demande de rapport n'a
malheureusement pas été adoptée ces
données aurait pourtant été très utiles
pour adapter au mieux la prise en charge
des enfants et la venue des parents dans
ce contexte dans ce contexte la sécurité
sociale prend en charge un billet
accompagnant seulement ce qui oblige le
deuxième parent à assumer le coût
financier seul de son de son déplacement
en ce sens un décret a été annoncé pour
ouvrir la prise en charge de ce deuxième
billet d'avion un autre membre de la
famille toutefois nous constatons que ce
décret tarde apparaître qu'en est-il
monsieur le ministre
je souhaite très terminer mon propos en
partageant l'importance à travers ce
texte de voir la solidarité nationale
prendre enfin sa part pour accompagner
les Aidants et se substituer la
solidarité familiale sur laquelle nous
nous sommes trop longtemps reposer pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe GDR votre a
pour cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole est à madame Béatrice descampe
ou le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues la survenue d'une maladie d'un
handicap d'un accident est toujours un
choc une épreuve qui change la vie
bousculent toute une famille
particulièrement lorsqu'un enfant est
concerné il faut toute la force du monde
lorsqu'on est parent et dans pour
affronter cette épreuve affronter
l'angoisse la tente de guérison les
traitements la souffrance l'impuissance
de la force aussi pour affronter des
situations qui pourraient être évitables
la perte de son travail de ses revenus
le risque de perdre son logement et
parfois des démarches administratives
pour solliciter un peu d'aide qui sont
de vrais parcours de combattants en tant
que législateur nous avons le devoir
d'écouter
et d'aider ce qui aide leur proche a
surmonter la maladie ou le handicap nous
avons la possibilité
d'éviter ce qui s'apparente comme une
double peine pour ses familles
c'est l'objet de cette proposition de
loi défendue par notre collègue Paul
Christophe que je salue et dont je salue
le combat
à combat que nous avons en commun un
combat qui nous unit tous élus par an
association
cette proposition comporte-t-elle des
avancées indéniables et dès le début
notre groupe a fait part de son soutien
c'est le cas de la protection contre le
licenciement et la garantie de pouvoir
recourir au télétravail des droits
indispensables car pour les parents
concernés concilier vie professionnelle
et vie personnelle devient presque
impossible c'est le cas également de
l'assouplissement des dispositifs
relatifs au congés de présence parentale
et à la location journalière de présence
parentale aujourd'hui notre groupe se
réjouit que cette proposition était
enrichie grâce au travail parlementaire
telle ces deux avancées concrètes que
notre groupe défend de longue date
la première concerne l'extension du
congé de deuil pour le décès d'un enfant
je rappelle qu'il s'agissait d'une
proposition de loi de mon collègue Guy
Bricout son adaption lors du précédent
quinquennat avait fait l'objet d'un
compromis et ne nous réjouissons
qu'aujourd'hui nous puissions renouer
avec l'ambition que nous avions
initialement porté
je salue l'extension de ce congé aux
agents publics opérés par le
gouvernement qui a fini par se ranger à
notre position rien ne permet de
consoler la perte d'un enfant mais si
nous avons les moyens d'accorder un peu
de répit aux familles alors nous devons
le faire
c'est le sens de ces amendements
la seconde avancée est celle relative à
l'extension du congé pour l'annonce
d'une pathologie ou de l'accident d'un
enfant en 2021 j'étais l'auteur d'une
proposition de loi sur le sujet qui a
permis d'inscrire ce droit nouveau dans
la loi j'avais alors dit que j'espérais
que selon moi c'était une première
pierre aujourd'hui nous améliorons ce
dernier et je ne peux commencer
c'est une manière de reconnaître ce
moment convient difficile vécu par les
familles confrontés à la maladie ou à
l'accident de leur enfant
c'est une façon de leur donner un peu de
temps pour faire face à cette nouvelle
qui changera leur vie parfois pour
toujours et surtout pour leur permettre
d'accompagner de leur enfant d'être à
ses côtés je pense aussi à
l'apprentissage thérapeutique et haut
des marches chronophages enfin je me
réjouis du maintien de l'article relatif
à la protection contre le risque de
rupture de bail par le propriétaire
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale c'est une
garantie supplémentaire pour ces
familles particulièrement les plus
modestes monsieur le ministre il restera
d'autres sujets vous l'avez dit
vous-même à aborder pour améliorer
davantage encore la protection des
familles d'enfants atteint d'une maladie
d'un handicap ou victime d'un accident
grave
je pense par exemple un favoriser le
développement de solutions pour loger
temporairement ces familles prédécentes
de soins qui se trouvent loin de leur
domicile
je pense particulièrement famille
ultramarine ou corse qui se retrouvent
doublement confrontés à des carences
dans l'offre de soins sur leur
territoire et aussi à des prix de
billets d'avion très élevés notre groupe
afin d'opter une proposition de loi
portée par Olivier Servat et Max matiasa
sur le sujet de la continuité
territoriale nous comptons sur
l'engagement du gouvernement pour
qu'elle celles-ci aboutissent il faudra
également revenir sur les durées
d'indemnisation des congés de présence
parentale et des congés de projets
gagneraient à être étendue plus
largement il faudra enfin nous poser la
question d'attribuer à ces familles un
vrai statut protecteur d'ici là notre
groupe soutiendra bien évidemment cette
proposition de loi
merci madame la députée
la parole est à Madame Servane Hugues
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
Paul Christophe mesdames et messieurs
les députés nous sommes aujourd'hui
réunis pour le vote d'un texte
extrêmement symbolique pour la
reconnaissance et la protection de
milliers de familles en France une
proposition de loi qui renforce les
droits des familles d'enfants atteint
d'une maladie ou bien d'un handicap ou
victime d'un accident d'une particulière
gravité elle est le fruit d'un travail
de concert des deux chambres de notre
Parlement français adopté à l'unanimité
à l'Assemblée nationale puis au Sénat ce
texte a fait l'objet d'un accord
conclusif la semaine passée en
commission mixte paritaire ce sont bien
des dispositions concrètes et efficaces
qui sont prévues là
un texte enrichi tant à l'Assemblée
nationale cosséna et ce toujours pour un
même objectif celui de soutenir les
enfants les familles d'enfants malades
vont en situation de handicap ces
enrichissements au cours de la navette
parlementaire permettront de protéger le
salarié face à au licenciement pendant
son congé de présence parentale mais
aussi pendant toutes les périodes
travaillées si ce congé est fractionné
ou pris à temps partiel
facilitation de la procédure de
renouvellement pour obtenir la location
journalière de procédant et le congé de
présence parentale renforcement du droit
au logement protection face au
licenciement ce sont tant d'amélioration
de notre droit que nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager
sur les 9 millions d'aidants en France
la moitié accompagne des personnes âgées
de moins de 60 ans et parmi eux un tiers
apporte une aide à son ou ses enfants
ils doivent alors assumer une
parentalité totalement bouleversée et
très souvent il manque d'informations et
d'accessibilité au service ou aux aides
existantes ses parents ce sont des mers
majoritairement qui s'arrêtent de
travailler ou réduisent leur temps de
travail
elles sont près de 40% parmi les mamans
d'enfants en situation de handicap à
être impactés professionnels
diminution ou cessation totale
d'activité professionnelle manque de
temps pour la recherche d'emploi refus
de promotion difficultés de
concentration s'occuper de son enfant
malade handicapé ou accidenté c'est
avant tout maître sa vie entre
parenthèses pour ce que l'on a de plus
cher au monde
trop souvent victimes d'isolement social
et affectif ses parents attendent des
garanties pour se maintenir en emploi
durablement des mesures de protection
supplémentaire une écoute sincère de
leur exigence familiale sens
stigmatisation ni jugement parce que oui
le travail est un levier d'insertion de
socialisation de stimulation dont ces
aidants doivent bénéficier dans des
conditions adéquates à leur situation
singulière ce texte et je remercie
encore chaleureusement Paul Christophe
pour son travail permettra de soutenir
des parents qui en plus du choc de
l'annonce de la maladie ou de la
réorganisation complète de leur famille
doit faire face à des problèmes de
maintien dans l'emploi souvent
accompagnés d'un monde crucial de
compréhension et de bienveillance de la
part des employeurs c'est donc
logiquement sans hésitation et pour
toutes ces raisons évoquées que le
groupe Renaissance votera en faveur de
ce texte je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Serge Müller pour le groupe
rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci bien
madame la merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
nous sommes ici pour exprimer nos
positions de vote suite à une CMP qui
nous pouvons nous en féliciter a été
conclusive je rappelle que ce texte a
pour objet d'améliorer le quotidien des
parents d'enfants malades en réduisant
autant que possible les différentes
obstacles administratifs et financiers
rencontrés par les familles tente dans
leur conciliation entre le la présence
parentale et la vie professionnelle
pendant que dans leur accès aux droits
pour cela les travaux à l'Assemblée et
au Sénat ont été constructifs et
complémentaires sur l'article premier
nous permettront aux parents salariés
devant devant prendre soin de leur
enfant atteint d'une maladie d'un
handicap ou victime d'un accident
particulièrement grave de bénéficier
d'un régime de protection amélioré
contre le licenciement y compris l'or de
période de reprise de contrat de travail
entre deux périodes de congés
j'ai fait partie de ces parents
d'enfants atteints par une affection
longue durée qui entre rendez-vous à
l'hôpital psychomotricienne psychologue
neurologue et examen complémentaires on
continue on continue de travailler il
était donc indispensable de permettre à
ses parents en congé de présence
parentale
de pouvoir s'occuper de leur enfant en
toute quiétude quand il pouvait
qu'auparavant s'en priver par crainte de
licenciement l'article 1 bis que nous
avons voté à l'unanimité est enrichie
par nos collègues au Sénat vise à porter
à 14 jours la durée minimale du congé
pour le décès d'un enfant de moins de 25
ans et à 12 jours quel que soit son âge
alors qu'il n'était que respectivement
de 7 et 5 jours jusqu'à présent
nous sommes tous conscients que rien ne
remplacera la perte d'un enfant et que
rien n'enlèvera le deuil d'une famille
entre déni colère dépression et en faire
acceptation le deuil est un long chemin
14 jours ni changeront rien mais cela
permettra aux familles de bénéficier
d'une durée d'appréhension plus décente
pour se soutenir se réunir et permettre
d'accomplir toutes les démarches qui en
découlent
sur la suppression de la condition
d'accord explicite du service de
contrôle médical pour procéder au
renouvellement de l'allocation
journalière de présence parentale nous
sommes là aussi tombés d'accord
tout en créant une accélération des
démarches administratives cet article
permet de créer une avance sur le
versement de la location journalière du
procédant qui était nécessaire et de bon
sens
je salue également
l'article 4 de cette proposition de loi
qui est consacrée au non salariés
agricole et alors conjoint
collaborateurs en supprimant le principe
décrètement de l'allocation journalière
du projet dans et de présence parentale
versée au non salarié de professions
agricoles non affiliés à l'Assurance
retraite et à leur conjoint et au non
salariat agricoles cessant leur activité
cet article était attendu car quel
combat que celui de travailler au chant
tout en devant prendre soin de son
enfant atteint d'une maladie ou d'un
handicap
beaucoup restent à faire pour l'accès
aux droits du milieu agricole cet
article est un bon début et j'espère
sincèrement qu'il permettra d'ouvrir une
voie dans nos consciences pour ceux qui
sont une des professions les plus
oubliées de France ce qui nous porte ce
qui nous nourrissent mais surtout ceux
qui subissent dans le cadre du dernier
PLFSS notre groupe avait bataillé afin
que de leur afin de le reconnaître de
meilleurs statuts tant sur leur retraite
que sur leur accès au droit nous
continuerons et j'espère que vous aussi
chers collègues
vous l'avez compris nous sommes dans
l'ensemble favorable au disposition de
ce texte notre groupe rassemblement
national
votera en sa faveur je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Karen érotique pour le groupe la
France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur collègue
lorsqu'on parle que son enfant est
touché par une infection longue durée
c'est toute une vie qui se voit
bouleversée et qui doit être repensée
dans l'urgence et la douleur
malgré la tristesse des parents soucieux
et inquiets pour leur enfant gravement
malade dans se démener tout en
continuant à aller au travail et de
s'occuper de ses frères et sœurs comme
si de rien n'était
ceci un aménagement du temps pour
effectuer d'innombrables démarches
administratives ainsi que des
rendez-vous médicaux
ces démarches administratives sont
longues laborieuses mais surtout
nécessaire pour obtenir ne serait-ce
qu'une carte d'invalidité pour leur
enfant
ou encore des aides financières
essentielles dans ces moments-là
de la même manière les rendez-vous
successifs à l'hôpital ou chez les
spécialistes sont éreintes et
angoissants pour les enfants mais aussi
pour les parents parfois peu rassurés
par le personnel soignant souvent
débordé
ainsi malgré le soutien et la bonne
volonté des proches des soignants des
agents des services sociaux ses parents
qui deviennent des aidants du jour au
lendemain se sentent bien souvent
démunis et seul face à la situation
le quotidien devient une lutte
permanente l'accès aux droits et l'accès
aux soins deviennent un parcours du
combattant
il était donc de notre devoir de
législateur de se pencher sur ce texte
avec attention pour soulager autant que
faire ce peu le quotidien de ces
familles dans une société inadaptée
encore plein d'embûches et validistes
je salue le travail de Monsieur leur
rapporteur Paul Christophe les débats se
sont déroulés de manière constructive et
sereine oui collègue c'est possible
quand on œuvre dans l'intérêt général
ces discussions ont permis l'adoption de
mesure portées par le groupe de la
France insoumise notamment nous avons
défendu l'allongement de la durée du
congé minimal pour parents suite au
décès de son enfant important de cinq
jours à 12 jours
notre amendement a été adopté à
l'unanimité puis renforcée par le Sénat
dont je salue également le travail et la
mobilisation sur le sujet
même si rien ne serait comblé le vide
laissé la tristesse causée par la perte
d'un enfant il était plus que nécessaire
d'allonger une période de congés qui
n'était tout simplement pas à la hauteur
des besoins des familles ces choses
faites aujourd'hui
de la même manière nous avons défendu un
amendement écrit en concertation avec la
Fédération grandir sans cancer
interdisant le congé pour vente ou
reprise d'un bien immobilier si le
locataire si les locataire pardon ont un
enfant victime d'une affection longue
durée cette proposition a été aussi
défendue par les socialistes d'un
amendement similaire qui a également été
adopté puis conservée par le Sénat
plus largement le texte protège les
licenciements des licenciements et des
mutations les parents d'enfants atteints
d'une infection longue durée et leur
assouplit l'accès aux aides financières
ces mesures positives et Nancy il est
vrai qu'il nous reste d'autres chantiers
à mener concernant les aidants et la
prise en charge des affections longues
durées ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que faciliter le télétravail pour les
parents est une mesure qui va dans le
bon sens mais considérer que le
télétravail comme la solution à tous les
soucis n’en n'est pas une
un définitive bien sûr cette proposition
ne lève pas toutes les difficultés qui
s'érigent dans la vie des familles
d'enfants touchés par une infection de
langue durée mais elle permet de
garantir une protection accrue pour les
familles concernées et de lever certains
nombres d'obstacles lourds et
contraignants
de fait le groupe LFI UPS soutiendra
évidemment cette proposition de loi qui
a su faire consensus au delà des
clivages je vous remercie merci madame
la députée
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick neuder
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
Paul Christophe mes chers collègues
apporter des réponses concrètes ou
familles dont l'enfant est victime d'une
maladie grave ou d'un accident de la vie
voilà une belle mission des législateurs
le 6 juillet dernier la commission mixte
paritaire regroupant députés et
sénateurs a donc trouvé un accord vers
une version finale de la proposition de
loi visant à renforcer la protection des
familles d'enfants atteint d'une maladie
ou d'un handicap ou encore victime d'un
accident d'une particularité
car mes chers collègues si un adulte
victime d'une situation grave bénéficie
de dispositifs qui le protègent tels que
le gel des crédits l'arrêt maladie ou la
protection de l'emploi ces dispositifs
ne s'appliquent pas aux enfants aux
parents dont l'enfant est malade
pourtant plus de 3000 familles
françaises sont concernées par un ou
plusieurs enfants victimes d'une
affection longue durée des familles trop
souvent confrontées à des obstacles
notamment des freins administratifs
alors même qu'elles sont engagées dans
une lutte quotidienne pour le bien-être
voir la survie de leurs enfants par
exemple certaines d'entre elles se
retrouvent contraintes de multiplier les
démarches auprès de l'administration
tout en faisant face à des délais
d'attente toujours plus long afin de
pouvoir jouir de leurs droits financiers
scolaires ou même d'une carte
d'invalidité pour leur enfant
ces familles peuvent même parfois être
confrontés à un manque de compréhension
de la part de leur employeur ou encore
de leur débiteur dans le paiement de
leur loyer le remboursement de leur
crédit ou bien encore de leur charge
fiscale
autrement dit tant de situations
injustes venant perturber en corps plus
la vie de ses parents alors même qu'il
traverse déjà une période difficile et
brutale
c'est pourquoi cette proposition de loi
qui faisait l'objet de cette CMP
permettra d'apporter des réponses
concrètes et opérationnelles aux
familles dont l'enfant est victime d'une
affection longue durée
au nom du groupe les républicains je
salue ici les deux chambres notre
Parlement qui ont su travailler ensemble
pour renforcer la protection de ces
familles et essayer d'améliorer leur
quotidien je remercie également au nom
du groupe les républicains le travail de
Paul Christophe que je salue et qui
parfois ces expériences de législateur
mais parfois deux parents nous rassemble
au delà des bancs de cet assemblée nous
nous réjouissons en effet que cette CMP
est pu être conclusive et permet
d'appliquer aux parents d'enfants
malades les mêmes mécanismes de
protection que pour les adultes victimes
d'une situation
identique
nous nous réjouissons que ce texte
modifie le Code du travail de telle
sorte par exemple à protéger les parents
du licenciement pendant leurs congés de
présence parentale allongé le congé pour
décès d'un enfant de 7 à 14 jours ou
encore garantir l'accès au télétravail
des salariés et dans un enfant gravement
malade où handicapé nous nous
réjouissons enfin aussi que cette
proposition de loi permet d'accélérer
les aides financières versées aux
parents ou encore qu'elle protège le
droit au logement des parents d'enfants
malades ou handicapés nous nous
réjouissons car nous les républicains
seront toujours au plus proche de ces
familles courageuses et pour qui doit
s'exercer pleinement la solidarité
nationale je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Anne bergance pour le groupe
démocrate modem et indépendant
[Applaudissements]
madame le Président Monsieur rapporteur
monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs chers collègues c'est
aujourd'hui la dernière étape pour une
proposition de loi nécessaire et
attendue par de nombreuses familles et
associations c'est également une marque
supplémentaire de l'investissement du
rapporteur Paul Christophe dont
l'engagement de longue date sur les
questions de protection et d'aide aux
parents d'enfants malades mérite d'être
rappelé je tiens ici à saluer la qualité
du travail fourni par les parlementaires
des deux chambres le texte a été débattu
et enrichi avec pragmatisme et consensus
ce texte porte diverses mesures ayant
pour finalité d'aider les parents dans
des situations complexes et douloureuses
dans son combat de tous les jours que
représente la maladie ou le handicap
dans une famille car oui c'est un combat
un combat de l'enfant contre sa maladie
mais aussi un combat de l'ensemble de la
famille qui doit soudainement faire face
aux différentes épreuves administratives
financières organisationnelles mais
aussi psychologique qu'implique cette
situation
ce texte s'attache donc à améliorer la
protection des parents et s'inscrit dans
la continuité des actions menées par le
gouvernement au cours des dernières
années je pense notamment à la loi de
2019 renforçant le soutien aux aidants
familiaux
à celle de 2021 contribuant à améliorer
les conditions de présence parentale
avec ce texte il est proposé de
renforcer la protection et
l'accompagnement des parents concernés à
travers des modifications du code du
travail en offrant une protection
complète au salarié en congé de présence
parentale ces derniers ne pouvant
désormais plus faire l'objet d'un
licenciement de même de ce statut sur un
modèle identique à celui que qui prévaut
pour les femmes enceintes un allongement
des durées minimales de congés en cas
d'essai de l'enfant ou d'annonce d'une
grave maladie également une meilleure
adaptation de l'organisation du travail
souvent contraint des parents en
facilitant l'accès au télétravail tout
l'enjeu étant de pouvoir concilier
temporairement vie professionnelle et
soin de l'enfant tant que cela est
nécessaire le texte propose également
d'accélérer les aides financières
versées aux parents les CAF pouvant
ainsi verser les avances sur la JPP sans
attendre la vie du service du contrôle
médical des caisses primaires
d'assurance maladie dans le cadre d'un
renouvellement
cette PPL apporte indéniablement de
nombreuses mesures de simplification et
de protection bienvenues au milieu de
famille impactées souvenons-nous que ce
sont près de 2500 enfants qui sont
diagnostiqués d'un cancer chaque année
je tiens cependant à rappeler qu'au-delà
des mesures que nous prenons des
améliorations du quotidien que nous
apportons il faut que ces dispositions
soient portées à la connaissance du
public concerné il est indispensable
qu'une bonne information sur l'ensemble
des dispositifs puissent parvenir aux
familles dès le diagnostic posé et se
poursuivent le long du traitement c'est
un renforcement de la démarche d'aller
vers qu'il nous faut opérer comme le
préconisait dans son rapport pop
Christophe notamment il faut améliorer
l'accompagnement des familles en
organisant des connexions directes entre
les organismes et les travailleurs
sociaux tout ceci au bénéfice des
familles vous l'aurez compris au regard
du soutien que visent à apporter cette
proposition de loi aux familles le
groupe démocrate votera en faveur de ce
texte je vous remercie merci madame la
députée je vous informe que sur le vote
de la proposition de loi issues de la
CMP je suis saisie par le groupe horizon
et apparenté d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
la parole
et
est
là il peut elle peut être quelqu'un
d'autre si vous le souhaitez
alors monsieur le rapporteur vous
souhaitiez prendre la parole vous avez 5
minutes
bonjour
En tout cas je voulais simplement
exprimer mes remerciements à l'endroit
de tous les orateurs qui viennent de
s'exprimer pour et bien parler au nom de
leur groupe et donc valider finalement
la cause est bien évidemment noble il
s'agit vous l'avez compris tous et
toutes de protéger finalement les
parents concernés d'améliorer les
dispositifs existants et puis de tendre
monsieur le ministre vers là aussi des
mesures de progrès au regard de
l'expérimentation qui sera proposée avec
le concours des caisses d'allocations
familiales et de lac neuf vous monsieur
ministre parce que effectivement jamais
on aurait pu également et bien avancer
sans votre concours et je pense en
particulier et bien à l'agenda que nous
avons quelque peu tordus je peux
m'exprimer ainsi pour dire que pour
glisser finalement une commission mix
paritaire et une deuxième lecture ici
même et au Sénat tout à l'heure pour
faire en sorte bien que ce texte puisse
être promulgué avant la fin du mois de
juillet ce qui reste quand même à l'aune
de nos agendas quelque chose d'assez
appréciable sinon tout cela aurait été
renvoyé à la fin de l'année voilà vous
remercier toutes et tous parce que
finalement si la situation de ses
parents va s'améliorer c'est bien grâce
à vous tous qui venait voter et bien
avec nous faveur blanc ce texte merci à
vous
merci monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous laisse tous regagner vos
places tranquillement
je suis consciente que ça fait pas 5
minutes et je vois que les députés
arrivent donc on va attendre
tranquillement tranquillement parce que
ça fait pas 5 minutes et je vois que les
collègues arrivent chers collègues donc
ah ben non vous parlerez pas après
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
non alors il y a la règle des 5 minutes
et je sais que des fois je vous fais le
coup des 5 minutes Fiat mais là je vois
des députés qui arrivent qui ont envie
de voter donc on va attendre
ne courez pas ne courait pas
on a combien là
nous ne sommes qu'à 3 minutes d'annonces
du scrutin et des collègues arrivent
donc là sincèrement je vais respecter
les 5 minutes
ne courez pas chers collègues ne tombez
pas dans les escaliers nous attendons
[Musique]
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin
je vais donc mettre au voile la
proposition de loi je vous prie de bien
vouloir regagner vos places le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 213
exprimés 213 majorités 107 pour 210
contre 3 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
la séance est suspendue pour trois
minutes